in a studio where people with
superpowers become outcasts subjugated
by androids a young man with
extraordinary abilities turns to crime
to help his ailing mother today on semi
recapped i'll show you
code 8 renegades the movie begins with
an explanation that in this world it was
discovered a long time ago that there
were people with superpowers so the
government has invited all those special
people to register in order to have some
kind of control a company also has
invited them to work with them to be
part of a new futuristic city since
people with superpowers will be key to
its construction in this new city
industrialization arrives and the news
reports that people's superpowers will
no longer be as required since machines
will replace them some companies also
declare that they will not hire people
with superpowers if they're not
registered because of all this we see
that there's a lot of unemployment and
hunger for many people then it is
explained that there's a new drug being
consumed by many people at the end of
the explanation we see that they created
robotic policemen for the protection of
humanity in the present we meet connor
and his mother who had fallen asleep on
the sofa in her uniforms and she has to
work very hard the boy prepares a coffee
for her while we see that the mother has
an illness that shows in her hands later
conor attends a job interview but it
doesn't go very well
so he leaves in his truck to go meet a
man who gives him temporary jobs
one of which is to build a house using
superpowers
meanwhile a giant drone arrives along
with a police patrol
they ask everyone to get out and
identify themselves
then the police tell the construction
manager that they heard rumors that he
has people working with superpowers
people who have not been registered but
the man denies it then they lined them
all up and asked them to look skywards
so the drone identifies that half of
them have powers but also that the last
one in line
did not obey the cops demand the man
look at the drone so he looks and the
drone quickly tells them that he's
someone wanted for crimes of the past at
that moment the drone opens its doors
and two robotic policemen come out at
the same moment the cops arrest the man
but he uses his powers to burn an
officer and then runs off
the drone drops the two robots which
promptly shoot the fleeing man later the
police and the drones go to a place
where they know there are dangerous and
armed people so some robots get off the
drones to support the police they enter
the building one robot goes ahead but a
man manages to damage it so the police
follow him and arrest him an officer
says that he found another room and when
they open it they find the famous drug
that has been sold lately in the streets
and they see that it's made by a liquid
extracted from the marrow of humans
later the chief of police gives a
statement in which he says that they
have been successfully fighting drug
traffickers
that night conor's mother is scolded by
her boss because she froze and broke a
sauce jar with her powers
at that moment her son arrives telling
the owner not to talk to his mother like
that
and he also threatens the boss with his
own superpowers
so the man fires his mom they go back
home arguing on the way
connor says that he saw the sauce frozen
on the floor and he tells his mother
that they have to start chemotherapy for
her but his mom tells him that they need
a lot of money for that and conor says
that he'll figure it out the next day
men with superpowers are waiting for
someone to stop and give them a
temporary job
but only one truck arrives which they
know is from a company that works
secretly producing the famously illegal
drug the truck approaches and the one
who drives it is a man named garrett who
asks for someone with electrical power
is level two
so conor signs up since he needs the
money
and they take him to a place where he
has to cut off the high voltage using
his powers conor overloads the fence and
the power goes out impressing his
contractors
they start to steal some containers but
the guard sees them although they
quickly take away his radio and leave
him locked in a garbage can later they
arrive at the place where they'll
deliver the merchandise there connor
meets the boss named marcus who can read
minds
he reads connors and realizes his
potential marcus takes garrett to talk
to him and tells him that there are more
bosses than him to whom he owes a lot of
money so they need to get it quickly
garrett takes the boy home and gives him
an extra bonus while telling him that
they'll have a new job for him soon
and also tells him that he has talent so
he should take advantage of it our
protagonist enters his house where he
finds that his mother got her job back
at the store
the boy gets upset but the mother tells
him they need the money so conor grows
thoughtful the next day conor is back on
the street waiting with the others to
see if someone will give them a job
a truck arrives to take them to a
construction site but garrett also
arrives
so the boy decides to go with him since
the pay is much better he has lunch with
them and garrett asks him what his
motivations are for working with them
since he likes to meet the people he
works with
the boy is honest with him telling him
that it's because of his mother's
illness
so garrett convinced he has good reasons
invites him to leave the restaurant and
explains it in the next few days
connor will be following garrett
everywhere
so he can train him and therefore they
can commit bigger robberies that night
conor lies to his mother telling her
that they called him to offer him a good
job
so he tells her that he will soon take
her to have her treatment done the next
day the robbers analyze the facilities
of a bank they intend to rob
but they will have to do it in less than
seven minutes the drone's response time
at night the robbers enter the bank
connor quickly disables the security of
the safe and the others force a girl
from the bank to open it manually
however garrett realizes that there is
very little money and the girl tells him
that every friday they emptied the vault
they take what's left and leave the
place then when they're outside a drone
arrives but conor performs a new kind of
electroshock towards the drone which
falls and explodes while the boys take
the opportunity to escape they arrive at
the club where marcus can't believe they
only got a little bit of money a young
woman who works for his superiors wants
to kill marcus but one of his men covers
him while conor electrocutes and disarms
her and someone else kills her shortly
after conor talks with another girl
named mia who always follows marcus and
he finds out that she has the power to
heal people since she heals his injured
arm later conor comes home where he
finds out that his mother discovered all
the money he had saved so she knows he's
doing illegal things
the boy tries to explain that he has to
do it in order to cure her the mother
refuses since the same thing happened to
her father who tried to steal money
the robot surprised him killing him in
cold blood then the mother begins to
feel bad so she inadvertently freezes a
glass and collapses conor holds her and
takes her to hospital where the doctor
tells him that she has a problem in her
head which causes her powers to activate
without any control so she needs an
emergency operation the doctor leaves
him to think for a while and then a
nurse shows him how much the operation
will cost
and he finds out that it's very
expensive he leaves the hospital with
some policemen take him to an
interrogation since they believe that he
has something to do with the robberies
he denies everything so the policemen
have to release him because they have no
evidence
then he meets with garrett and tells him
what happened during the interrogation
they go to marcus to propose a new job
an ambitious one since they'll try to
steal very valuable merchandise the only
payment he wants in exchange for the job
is mia
since he wants to take her to heal his
mother
while garrett wants half of the loot
because he wants to be a partner marcus
has no choice but to accept so they
start planning the next big heist
together while mia starts to get angry
since they're only using her for the
convenience of others the plan begins
they wait for the truck that brings the
merchandise and then garrett interrupts
the truck's path while conor
electrocutes the vehicle along with two
of the four robots that were escorting
it garrett subdues the other two robots
with his powers but he can't stop them
for long so conor takes the opportunity
to disable them they try to escape but
marcus betrays them taking the
merchandise while garrett's team is
under fire
they hide and at the same time some more
drones arrive and drop two of their
robots garrett and his team escape while
the robots kill marcus men
the next day conor secretly asks to meet
with a policeman who has intentions to
solve the case conor convinces the
officer to work together with him and
catch marcus so that he can take mia to
cure his mother conor also informs him
that in the end he will turn himself
into the police voluntarily to pay for
his crimes later the police prepare to
catch marcus entering the location and
starting to kill his men
marcus tries to escape through the back
door but garrett arrives and shoots him
although one of his men covers him and
stays to fight garrett and connor work
together to finish off the man and then
they go after marcus to end his life
since he betrayed them before conor
wants to take mia to heal his mother
but she tells him that it's not that
simple showing them that by healing
people she acquires the damage in her
own body garrett gives conor a gun to
force mia to go heal his mother
so they go to the hospital and she
begins healing
but conor changes his mind and stops her
since it's an unfair situation
then connor leans over his mother
she sees him and tries to speak to him
but her illness takes her away and she
dies in front of her son
later conor stops his car outside the
police station
gifting the vehicle to mia so that she
could be free while he will turn himself
into the police the end if you liked the
video please leave a like and subscribe
to continue receiving recaps of the best
action and drama series and movies
thanks for watching